[Music]
I'm sure you didn't see this coming
you are oscar-nominated I mean for no
money yeah that's crazy it's pretty
pretty heavy stuff
yeah and now first of all how does it
feel to you get the phone call that you
were nominated for an Oscar for a song
you wrote very exciting it was in New
Zealand so I was it was very early in
the morning
so I was a little groggy but still very
exciting yeah it's a great way to wake
up and then I found out there only two
songs being nominated this year there's
only I thought it'd be it's like one of
six or one of seven seven yeah no
there's five there's only two so the
chances of winning of very as high as
they possibly could be because into the
Oscars with a 50-50 chance unless there
was one nominee yeah which would which
would make the ceremony really the
ceremony will be very predictive so uh
so you're one of so you've got a real
good shot at this thing yes me and
Sergio Mendes 50% H okay that's not a
joke that's real it's you and Sergio are
up against each other yes you're gonna
go to the Oscars you could come back did
you I'm just curious
you got this because you wrote a song
for the Muppet movie yeah
did you you grew up in New Zealand did
you know about the Muppets if they had
where the Muppets on television um yeah
the Muppet seemed to be on they were on
television everywhere I think but in New
Zealand yeah I grew up with them there
were only two channels in New Zealand
when I grew up
now there's four right everything you
say they find the true stuff um yeah so
there are two channels so you can watch
The Muppets or you know literally the
news or the other very popular show was
the dog show which I don't think you
guys got here which was about sheepdogs
and it was oh it's not the dog like a
Westminster Dog Show a competition is
petition it's sheepdogs on the hill a
rustling the Sheep and there's a farmer
this is this was the most popular TV
show you the elevator
this is classic Sunday night family
entertainment sit down watch the dog
show and so it's a wide shot of a green
hill and the dogs - dogs running up each
side getting the Sheep into a pen
that's it Annabelle was competitive so
it was like sheepdog versus other
sheepdog and yes in it you know the
heats went on I was like the Olympics I
just like to know that right now and New
Zealand that show is kicking my ass
[Laughter]
laughing at me
okay I have to ask you because the I
know the Lord of the Rings films are
shot in New Zealand and that you've had
the opportunity to be in one or two of
them too and a bit too in a bit yeah two
point three that I've been in too and
then I'm gonna be in the fourth one
which is the Hobbit you're gonna be in a
lot of the Rings part four
this is very cool that these are the
ones that you've already been in you've
had small very small very small I mean
the first one I was an extra in the
background next to Aragorn okay and I'm
an elf so when I've got when a
clean-shaven with pointy ears I look
very elven we have I think we have a
still from the one second that you're on
camera so I think let's go in can we go
in tighter I think where are you oh
there you are
[Applause]
[Music]
you're doing a good job of acting very
concerned about something that was a big
deal that was one though accusing who's
gonna take the ring oh okay
it's your role in the next one a little
bigger in this I have a couple of lines
oh yes it's quite a big role is a big
deal if like with your family is it a
big deal that you're in these films well
I'm from Wellington which is where Peter
Jackson makes the films so it's not that
uncommon to be in them my dad was a king
oh he's done it my older brother was
another elf and my younger brother
didn't get this part has not been in the
movies he was select New York and law
and order everyone's there
that's all we got what do we go that's
in always says at the bottom is good
luck at the Oscars pow yes but you don't
need a big finish with this one it's
such a it's great great having you on
the show I'm a big fan and I'm rooting
for you thanks I don't know what Sergio
did I want you to win this thing thanks
man you're gonna get it it's gonna be
here Bret McKenzie everybody thank you